all smiles as world leaders and global
figures in the fight against climate
change prepare to head home from cop26
in glasgow
there has been a barrage of
announcements america promoting a global
deal to cut
methane the royal family out in force
adding to a general sense of momentum
boris johnson focusing on a major
agreement to end deforestation by 2030
although there's some criticism that it
lacks teeth there are concerns that
brazil might sign on the dotted line
but it's still got a big problem with
illegal forestry
what is your assessment of that
situation well you're not incorrect by
saying illegal forestry is a big
challenge but what we're bringing to the
table right now is a level of commitment
we cannot let carbon sinks be be just
taken away from us and if we do that we
have a shot at this 1.5 and i'm hoping
it's more than just a shot
progress on keeping 1.5 degrees of
warming within reach but a thorny
problem persists as delegates shuttle
between meetings the issue that
permeates nearly every discussion is
money
poorer nations say that so far rich
countries have delivered too little too
late it is a fault line that threatens
this summit
china is very focused on this issue
delays to a hundred billion dollars of
global funding a particular concern
there is still a large gap between the
support required and
support provided
they
failed to deliver their commitment
before 2020 which has a
negative impact on the mutual trust
between developed and developing
countries u.s special envoy on climate
change john kerry knows that this is a
matter of credibility that more needs to
happen and quickly a hundred billion
dollars doesn't do it folks
it's trillions of dollars that are
needed
and the only way we will get this done
is if trillions of dollars are
forthcoming and they are
tomorrow there'll be an announcement i'm
not going to jump the announcement
but there will be tens of trillions of
dollars announced
that are available to be invested
invested
in
this transition
for the climate vulnerable this is a
matter of survival if we don't
turn the tide around now
there'll be no more islands
and then when there's no more islands
there's no culture there's no language
and they're gone
bill gates announcing millions more to
push green innovation along is hopeful
but realistic about the challenges ahead
if i look at
where we were six years ago where the
private sector was not being engaged not
providing its expertise and resources
and when we weren't talking about
innovation and how we were going to make
green products
cost
equal or even less than the products
they replace but i wouldn't
understand this is a hard problem
humanity has never done anything this
hard almost everyone gathered here
agrees
a monumental challenge at a critical
time
time that is running out